I’ve invited you all here today because
I wanted to talk to you about some
ugly stereotypes that are going around.
I’ve been hearing a lot of unfair, unseemly, and
unscientific generalizations being made lately.
And they mostly have to do with sex. And your hormones.
People have a nasty habit of equating “hormones”
with a particular set of behaviors and conditions,
most of which have to do with reproduction,
or sexual development, or acts that include
what my brother John has referred to as “skoodilypooping.”
For example, people will say that “hormones”
are why Kevin has zits, and is being all moody,
or why Hannah, who’s three months pregnant,
just cried watching a commercial for car insurance
-- which, let’s be honest, I do that too.
Now, I’m not saying that hormones aren’t
at the root of sexual attraction, or zits,
or occasional bouts of extreme emotion, because
they are. That’s just not all that they do.
Not even close.
When people talk about “hormones” in
the contexts that I just mentioned,
what really they mean is "sex hormones."
But sex hormones are just one kind of hormone
that you have coursing through your body right now.
In fact, there are at least 50 different types
of these chemical messengers at work in your
body at this very minute, but only a very few
of them have anything at all to do with sex.
The truth is, from birth to death, just about
every cell and function in your body is under
your hormones’ constant influence.
They’re floating through your blood, regulating
your metabolism, your sleep cycle, your response
to stress, and the general and incredibly important
overall homeostasis that keeps you not dead.
Some hormones are just there to make other
hormones trigger even more hormones -- in
a kind of chemical relay race that biologists
refer to, rather elegantly, as “cascades.”
These hormones run through you no matter what
your mood is, or whether you have zits.
So the reality is: We’re all hormonal ... all
of the time.
OK, to begin to understand our hormones -- and
the endocrine system that produces, releases,
and re-absorbs them -- we have to step back
and take a broad view.
Not just by emphasizing that sex hormones aren’t
the only hormones you have -- but also by
looking at how your hormones interact with
your other organ systems.
Because, if anything, your body has two bosses
-- two complementary systems that are constantly
shouting instructions over each other, to
all of your bits and pieces.
Both your endocrine system and your nervous
system are constantly trafficking information
around your corpus, gathering intel, making
demands, controlling your every move. They
just have totally different ways of doing
it.
Your nervous system uses lightning-fast
electrochemical action potentials,
delivered by an expressway made of
neurons to specific cells and organs.
But your endocrine system prefers a slower,
wider stream of data.
It secretes hormones that travel through your
blood -- NOT through neurons -- so they move more
slowly, but they also produce widespread effects
that last a whole lot longer than an action potential.
Now, compared to your heart or brain or other,
arguably more glamorous organs, your endocrine
system’s organs and glands are kinda small
and lumpy.
They’re also rogues -- instead of being all
nestled together like in your other organ systems,
these guys are scattered all over the place, from your
brain to your throat, to your kidneys, to your genitals.
A gland is a just any structure that makes
and secretes a hormone. And the master gland
in your body is the pituitary, which produces
many hormones that signal other glands -- like
the thyroid, parathyroid, adrenal, and pineal
glands -- to make their own hormones.
The endocrine system also includes a few organs
-- like the gonads, the pancreas, and the
placenta in pregnant women -- all of which
have some other non-hormonal functions and
are made up of multiple tissue types.
And technically the hypothalamus in your brain
is in the endocrine club too, since in addition
to all of its busy brain duties, it does produce
and release hormones.
So, thanks to these glands and organs, you’ve got
all these hormones diffusing through your blood,
doing all sorts of different things, but the thing to
remember about them is that a hormone can only
trigger a reaction in specific cells -- their so-called
target cells -- that have the right receptors for it.
So, just like some keys can open many locks,
while others only work with one, so too can
the hormone-target-cell relationship either
be widespread or localized.
You’re probably gonna want an example of
that. So, your thyroid -- at the bottom of
your throat -- produces the hormone thyroxine,
which stimulates metabolism and binds to receptors
in most of the cells in your body.
But your pituitary -- which is nestled all
comfy under your brain -- produces follicle-stimulating
hormone, which helps regulate growth and triggers
sexual maturity, and it only targets specific
cells in the ovaries and testes.
So how do hormones bind to their target cells?
Well, chemically, most hormones are either
made of amino acids -- including their more
complex structures like peptides or proteins
-- or they’re derived from lipids, like cholesterol.
And this is key, because a hormone’s chemical
structure determines if it’s water soluble,
like most amino acid-based ones are, or lipid
soluble, like steroids are.
Solubility is important because your cell
membranes are made of lipids.
That means that water soluble ones can’t
get across them. So target cells for those
kinds of hormones have receptors for them
on the outside of their membranes.
Lipid-soluble hormones, on the other hand,
can just basically glide right through that
cell membrane, so their receptor sites are
inside their target cells.
Either way, when a target cell is activated,
the hormone alters its activity, by either
increasing or decreasing some of its functions
-- usually with the goal of maintaining your
body’s homeostasis in one way or another.
So, if hormones are keeping your body IN balance,
what’s putting your body out of balance?
I don’t know -- could I interest you in
some pie?
If you have a couple of nice, generous helpings
of strawberry-rhubarb pie -- and just to make
things interesting, let’s say they’re a la mode --
your blood glucose level is gonna go through the roof.
And the pancreas regulates your blood sugar by
releasing two different hormones -- insulin and
glucagon. Once you have a belly full of that pie,
beta cells in your pancreas release insulin, which
helps lower your blood sugar by increasing
the rate at which your cells store the sugar
either as glycogen or as fat for later use.
Now, let’s say you’ve done the opposite:
You’ve eaten no pie -- you’re pie-less
-- in fact, you’ve eaten nothing for hours.
If your blood sugar drops too low, then alpha
cells in the pancreas will instead send out
glucagon, which helps raise your blood sugar
levels, in part by decreasing the storage
of sugar in your cells, and triggering their
release of glucose back into the blood.
Lots of different endocrine-related illnesses
-- like diabetes or hyperthyroidism -- tend
to be the result of either hyper (too much)
or hypo (too little) secretion of certain
hormones, which throw your homeostasis off
balance.
But there are lots of more common -- and less
obvious -- ways your hormones can get out
of balance, not because of some disorder,
but because these signaling chemicals are
just caught up in a chain reaction, which
can take a while to subside.
Some hormones just exist to control other
hormones, which in turn control still more hormones.
So as soon as one starts to trickle out, you can
pretty quickly wind up with a cascade on your hands.
You’ve got a few different hormone cascades
going on at any given moment, but one of the
big ones -- one that’s really worth understanding
-- is the hypothalamic-pituitary-adrenal axis,
or the HPA axis, because you don’t want
to have to say that every time.
This is a complex series of interactions between
three glands that ultimately regulates lots
of your body’s daily processes, like digestion, sexuality,
immune response, and how you handle stress.
And it’s complex not just because of all
the glands involved -- it’s also one of
the more crucial instances of your endocrine
system coordinating with your nervous system.
Specifically, it’s behind that fight-or-flight
response that everybody keeps talking about.
The HPA Axis is essentially the endocrine system’s
companion to the sympathetic nervous system.
The sympathetic system, in times of high stress,
does things like speed up your heart rate
and direct blood away from the digestive organs
and to the muscles.
But many of the other effects of the stress
response are carried out by your endocrine
system. And getting your nervous and endocrine
systems to work together in times of crisis
is where the hypothalamus comes in.
It’s the hub of where the two systems meet
-- it keeps tabs on what’s going on all
over your body, analyzing your blood for signs
that something might be off.
So, let’s revisit our fight-or-flight scene from a few
lessons ago -- the old Burning House Scenario.
So you’re sleeping, dreaming about petting pandas with
Emma Watson or whatever, when the smoke alarm
goes off. Well, action potentials in your brain trigger
neurons in your hypothalamus to release the peptide
hormone CRH, or corticotropin releasing hormone.
The CRH makes the very short trip through
the bloodstream to the anterior pituitary
gland, where, because it’s water soluble, it
binds to receptors on the outside of its target cells.
There, it triggers the release of adrenocorticotropic
hormone, or ACTH. The ACTH travels -- again
through the bloodstream -- to the adrenal cortices
of the adrenal glands on top of your kidneys.
When the ACTH binds to receptors on cells
in an adrenal cortex, it triggers the release
of a frenzy of different freak-out compounds known
as glucocorticoid and mineralcorticoid hormones.
Typically these guys help us deal with day-to-day stress
by keeping our blood sugar and blood pressure
balanced. But under major stress -- like waking up
in a burning building stress -- these hormones,
like cortisol, cause the classic fight-or-flight
response: ramping up your blood pressure,
dumping glucose into your bloodstream, shutting
down non-emergency services like your immune
system and sperm and egg development.
And guess what? Now that all these stress
hormones are pulsing through your blood, the
hypothalamus back in the brain senses them.
And because its job is to monitor and maintain
balance whenever possible, it then stops secreting
CRH, which -- eventually -- causes the other
glands to stop secreting their panic hormones.
Now, because this element of the stress response
is hormonal rather than electrical, it comes
on more slowly than the nervous system part,
and it takes longer to subside, too, as those
stress hormones linger in the blood before
being broken down by enzymes.
So. We’re a long way from teenage crushes and zits
and crying over commercials at this point, aren’t we?
As a life-long owner of hormones, I hope you’ll
join me in dispelling the stereotypes that
surround these powerful and important chemicals,
and give them the respect they rightly deserve.
Today we looked at the endocrine system, and
how it uses glands to produce hormones. These
hormones are either amino-acid based and water
soluble, or steroidal and lipid-soluble, and
may target many types of cells or just turn
on specific ones. We also touched on hormone
cascades, and how the HPA axis effects your
stress response.
Thank you to our Headmaster of Learning, Thomas
Frank, and to all of our Patreon patrons who
help make Crash Course possible through their
monthly contributions. If you like Crash Course
and you want to help us keep making free educational
content for the whole world, you can go to
patreon.com/crashcourse.
Crash Course is filmed in the Doctor Cheryl
C. Kinney Crash Course Studio. This episode
was written by Kathleen Yale, edited by Blake
de Pastino, and our consultant is Dr. Brandon
Jackson. It was directed by Nicholas Jenkins,
the editor is Nicole Sweeney, the script supervisor
was Stefan Chin, our sound designer is Michael
Aranda and the graphics team is Thought Café.